Tom Brady has retired again
good morning guys I'll get to the point
right away I'm retiring
for good
I know the process uh was a pretty big
deal last time so when I woke up this
morning I figured I just pressed record
and let you guys know first so I won't
be long-winded if you only get one super
emotional retirement essay and I used
mine up last year so I really thank you
guys so much to every single one of you
for supporting me my family
my friends my teammates
my competitors
I could go on forever there's too many
thank you guys for allowing me to live
my absolute dream
I wouldn't change the thing
love you all love you all now a year
after I retired
then came back I'm retiring again
I don't have any uh particular care that
Tom Brady is retiring again I'm not a
New England Patriots fan I'm a New
Yorker by birth and upbringing I don't
watch football I don't even know what
team Tom Brady currently plays for or
did play for before he retired my
interest in this story goes back much
further than Tom Brady's football career
goes back way back to ancient days it
goes back to a man you might have heard
of a fella by the name of Hezekiah king
of Judah
Hezekiah king of Judah you can read
about him in the Bible
was a very good ruler
of Judah he was a very successful King
and one day the prophet Isaiah comes to
him and he says hey you're going to die
you're sick and you're gonna die and
your time has come and Hezekiah says oh
man I don't want to die Isaiah come on I
want to get can I give me some more
years come on talk to God get me some
more years
and Isaiah comes back and he says hey
you've been granted a reprieve God is
giving you another 15 years
and Hezekiah says oh man that's great
and what happens
Hezekiah
destroys his legacy
in that 15-year period Hezekiah welcomes
the Babylonians to come in check out his
kingdom check out all of his stuff if
they had had spy balloons during that
day the Babylonians would have been
sending that over although I guess they
didn't need to because Hezekiah just
invited them in and gives them a huge
upper hand in what would come later
which is the Babylonians just Conquering
the kingdom in that 15-year period of
time Hezekiah king of Judah has a son
his son is Manasseh Manasseh is a very
terrible King who tears down all the
great stuff that Hezekiah had done
and Hezekiah sees that this is going to
happen and Isaiah says you know man
things are going to go really South
you you were supposed to die but then
you know you got this little reprieve
and you're going to destroy everything
and what does Hezekiah say he says well
is this going to happen in my lifetime
Isaiah says no no it's going to happen
after you're dead and Hezekiah says oh
okay all right never mind well in that
case I get another 15 years it's pretty
nice right
was it worth it
I don't think so
and by the whole scope of Salvation
history you know it all all comes to a
purpose ultimately
but in the moment certainly wasn't good
for Judah certainly wasn't good for
hezekiah's legacy
certainly wasn't good
certainly wasn't good for Tom Brady
a real important reminder
know your time
know when things are over Tom Brady
could have retired a year ago he would
have gone out as the almost universally
beloved greatest football player of all
time with a super hot wife that people
generally liked and a nice family and he
could have rode off into the sunset
instead he decided to unretire this has
been broadly cited as the reason why his
wife divorced him and lost him a lot of
favor among the fans and for what
to get one more year and then he says
okay I'm out
was it worth it to just wring out
another few months of playing football
probably not was it worth it Hezekiah
just to ring out another 15 measly years
on Earth you destroy the kingdom of
Judah I don't think so
now I mentioned I mentioned those uh
hostile foreign powers coming in and
spying around on on kingdoms this is a
story that just broke last night the the
Chinese have apparently sent a spy
balloon over the continental United
States my first reaction is
is this 1952 are we we're still sending
spy balloons
don't we have more advanced technology
than that don't the Chinese Chinese are
very Advanced they stole all of our Tech
surely surely the Chinese have more
advanced Tech than this apparently not
so there's this spy balloon
and it's it's uh going over here and the
uh foreign affairs spokesman for the
Chinese whose name is Mao not a good
sign also mounting Mao says I want to
stress that before it becomes clear what
happened to any deliberate speculation
or hyping up will not help the Chinese
side is gathering the facts
and hopes all sides will handle this
matter in a cool headed manner
we act in accordance with international
law says Ming or says Mao ning I kind of
push those two together it says we have
no intention to violate any other
country's sovereignty and bearing the
facts we hope relevant parties would
handle the matter in a clear-headed way
yeah okay yeah China famous for acting
in accordance with international law
China which starting the moment we let
them into the World Trade Organization
starts violating all the trade rules
steals all of our technology
artificially subsidizes steel and
aluminum aluminum artificially
manipulates its currency just does
everything it can to violate
international law to say nothing of what
it does to various population groups
within China and just all the heinous
things that the regime inflicts on its
people
yeah we action accordance with
International Love so what is the Biden
Administration doing
now the Biden Administration I was
wondering I said okay what is this
balloon look like and we don't know
exactly because it's still flying
overhead
what they said they're monitoring the
situation they're they've got eyes on it
they're monitoring the Spy balloon are
you kidding me
are you is this the depth of weakness
that the United States has sunk to
that we see a spy balloon flying over
the continental United States
we know it's from
our most threatening geopolitical foe
China
and we just let it keep flying we don't
shoot this thing down
what are we spending all this money on
in the U.S military
all that defense spending that we get
every year we can't even shoot down a
stupid balloon good grief man
you know back in the 50s
when the U.S was sending spy planes over
the Soviet Union
when there was a a far greater risk of a
nuclear war than you have right now
between America and the United States or
in America and China rather what what
did the Soviet Union do they shot the
plane down
the plane which wasn't just a random
balloon the plane that had a pilot in it
and the U.S denied oh no we don't have
any spy plans over the Soviet Union and
then they shoot down the plane and we
say okay all right I guess we did
and now
we're so afraid of upsetting China that
we'll let that we will allow them
to send a spy balloon over the U.S good
grief
the reason we're doing it of course is
because China sort of owns us at this
point
they own a ton of our debt
they own our entire
production line they own our supply
chain
they if they cut us off if we're a
little too aggressive with China
well then
then we're screwed
this is what happens for a long time
you heard people on among the liberal
free Trader types especially Joe Biden
he was really clear about this he said
oh we need to bring China into the
International Community we need to trade
with them a rising tide lifts All Ships
it's really good Rising China is good
for everybody
you know what let's let's give them all
of our manufacturing yeah I know that'll
hurt small town Americans that'll hurt
blue-collar Americans but that's doesn't
matter because now we'll get cheap junk
from China and that'll be really really
great for everybody and there's no
downside to Total free trade and
offshoring and Outsourcing there's no
downside at all because GDP might tick
up a little bit this is what you heard
from the free Traders not just in the
Democrat Party in the Republican party
too and there were some people some of
those less fashionable figures who said
actually maybe we need some
Manufacturing in the U.S actually maybe
it's not going to Outsource our entire
manufacturing base actually maybe
tariffs wouldn't be the worst idea
actually maybe we should counter China's
rise and these people were laughed at as
Rubes economically illiterate stupid
idiots
and now now what situation are we in
we're in a situation where
China calls the shots
because he who pays the piper calls the
tune GDP is not everything free trade is
not universally good at all times in
every way and actually it might serve
the purposes of National Security might
serve our national political flourishing
for us to be able to make some things
ourselves and not be
totally owned and operated by our
enemies
the show continues now
not for you Hoy polloi over on YouTube
but for the creme de La Creme the Inner
Circle at dailywire.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout you get two months
free on all annual plans we will see you
there
[Music]